básicamente el exprocurador jesús
murillo pues fue el constructor de lo
que se le llama en méxico la verdad
histórica que quiere decir que ubica a
los 43 alumnos de ayotzinapa en una
hoguera gigantesca en el programa de
cocula donde son incinerados por el
grupo criminal de los guerreros unidos
lo cual pues ya ha desmentido
el actual gobierno el partido
revolucionario institucional el llamado
pri aseguró que la detención del ex
funcionario no trae justicia a las
familias sino que se trata de un tema
político y acusó al gobierno y al
oficialismo de persecución política que
nos puede decir al respecto
tenemos en estos momentos el pri es una
de las prácticas más denostados por la
sociedad debido a su participación en la
clase de corrupción durante muchos años
se trata de el primer funcionario de
alto rango que es capturado después de
ocho años y que es imputado por
delitos de desaparición forzada por
acusación ausàs acusaciones de tortura y
por este delitos contra la
administración de justicia entonces se
trata de un gran paso pero todavía
tienen que
invocarlo y que esta imputación sea
legal para que pueda proceder un juicio
realmente a él se le puede acusar por el
papel que desempeñó se le puede acusar
de tortura y desaparición forzada en
estos momentos hay seis testigos seis
víctimas de tortura que están señalando
lo como como responsable de estos
delitos entre ellos se encuentran
dos padres de familia de los
desaparecidos entonces es muy probable
que si se pueda
y que sigue ahora en el proceso contra
murillo
tendrán que explicarlo precisamente en
el de manera legal en las acusaciones
que se le está haciendo y después pues
hacerle una serie de juicios que
demuestren justamente que está
participando participó en las
acusaciones en los actos de tortura que
es lo que viene para ello